à la veille des césars nous recevons ce
soir l'une des grande triomphatrice des
dernières victoires de la musique
véronique sanson avant son spectacle au
zénith à partir de mardi jusqu'au 14
mars spectacle répétait à los angeles
tout le mois dernier et nourrit en
grande partie des chansons de son
dernier album sans engrais dont votre
plus grand succès commercial
véronique vous en avez vendu déjà plus
de 300 milles c'est ça à ce jour
arriverait exquise
vous serez accompagné sur cette scène du
zénith par onze musiciens des coeurs et
des percussions christian hottin a eu le
privilège de films est l'une des
répétitions en gardant tout de suite un
extrait
les cours et même personnage
mais son recul
ils ont joué du piano
alors il arrivera dira bonjour
et j'en vendrais son parent je vis dans
les
véronique bonsoir merci d'être là pour
vous la scène c'est le pied absolu comme
on dit maintenant
pourtant au début vous étiez pas très
très chaude pour faire ce genre de
prestation et vous raconter que même
maintenant vous êtes plus en plus le
trac et quelquefois ou fait des
cauchemars horrible vous arrivez sur
scène tout nuit vous êtes incapable de
jouer au piano c'est ça mais c'est vrai
dans la réalité aussi
sauf que j'arrive tout ça de toute scène
tournus oui bien sûr non mais c'est vrai
que la scène c'est quand même la cerise
sur le gâteau et que c'est la plus belle
récompense du monde parce qu'on joue sa
musique devant des gens qui aiment bien
écoutez donc c'est c'est très gratifiant
en 89 vous aviez joué avec l'orchestré
symphonique de prague cette fois ci
c'est une version un peu plus rock plus
oui quand même parce que il ya des
tuiles il ya des percussions et de
batterie il ya c'est pas le même drive
c'est pas la même mais si les mêmes
chansons certaines d'entre elles alors
précisément vous avez commencé très
jeune mais vous avez quand même vingt
ans de carrière
dix albums c'est sa compagne parce que
moi on a toujours 20 ans de carrière
d'accord mais bon c'est dix albums
voilà dix peu près dix ans une centaine
de chansons tout que vous avez
entièrement composer vous même je fais
des orchestrations vous faites vraiment
ou vous même justement vous disiez il ya
une partie des chansons qui seront les
mêmes comment on fait le choix quand on
a devant soi un répertoire d'une
centaine de chansons
comment vous construisez le spectacle
les contes des succès de vos goûts
personnels de d'un équilibre entre ce
qu'ils rapide plus lent oui bien sûr il
faut et qui est une progression
naturelle et puis on tient compte de ses
goûts personnels et puis des choses que
les gens aiment bien écouter aussi mais
plus on a d'albums plus c'est difficile
de choisir naturellement parce qu'on
peut pas faire un spectacle de quatre
heures
donc c'est assez difficile et assez
contraignant et ça fait des petits crise
en aura des chansons totalement inédites
qu'on n'a jamais entendu une au début au
milieu à la fin ça n'a aucune importance
à je pense que elle sera là l'un de vos
plus grands succès rien que de l'eau
vous êtes contente de la montée actuelle
sur le plan électoral des écologistes
assure avi je suis ravie si vraiment il
fonde et ils sont efficaces alors là je
suis ravi vraiment vous avez eu quelques
problèmes il ya quelques quelques années
avec une chanson qui s'appelait à la le
savoir qu'est ce que vous pensez
réellement ddd pas des malheurs mais des
tribulations de salman rushdie
je trouve ça épouvantable parce que
c'est un type qui je pense finira par se
faire avoir
parce qu'il ya toujours des fanatiques
partout et que même si on enlève le
contrat de sa tête il y aura toujours un
type qui se dira et oui je vais
l'assassiner et j'irai certainement au
paradis pour l'avoir fait c'est
effrayant d'avoir d'avoir fait d'avoir
dit que c'était bien de faire ça de dire
bon il faut tuer quelqu'un parce qu'il a
écrit des choses ça c'est mon jeu vous
avez terminé sur note un petit peu grave
nous avons hélas rendre l'antenne je
rappelle donc à vos nombreux admirateurs
et admiratrices que vous êtes sur la
scène du zénith à partir de mardi
je suppose que toute façon la location
lisbourg et s'est plaint que je croise
les doigts
je trouves tu vois pas de table il n'y a
pas de boue ainsi on dirait que c'est
des voix merci beaucoup puisque vous
êtes une